il a aussi quatre là notre chroniqueur
et on va voir sa répartie ça va du tout
de suite avant lui mais c'est assez
récent et misson il est tellement
content que cyril l'embauché que il
passe son temps elle flatte et elle lui
lécher les brumes
mais je lui dis tout le temps je me bats
pas la prendre mais il le fait avec
naïveté candeur et c'est plutôt touchant
bryson week et pas assez payés maxime
guénon avant bah oui parce qu'il a une
poignée de main et met sa cause il est
tellement content je pense même district
a pas de venir et de payer lui pour
venir donc ça nous arrangerait ben ça me
dérange aussi fait n'est qu'un vulgaire
imposteur la voleuse de maxime gagné le
deuxième et le cuir et peau cris de
voleurs vous aviez dit connais pas
encore tous débuts en est cette fois
liée à l'évasion
j'ai dit que c'était un vulgaire
imposteur premièrement deuxièmement tu
n'es que le plus gros époque rien que la
terre n'ait jamais créé waouh
mais bon c'est de le faire mais ta boîte
à camembert
[Applaudissements]
ce que j'aime c'est la tête de pascal et
de cuisine
c'est à dire qu'on dirait balladur qui
classe gt2 faille ou par jean michel
maire c'est comme s'ils qu'un mode r d
et roquefort tu premier lécheurs de
coucougnettes à sa palette